guys i gotta be honest with you i suck
at 3d modeling even though it was the
thing that got me into 3d
in the first place a few weeks ago i
tried to
livestream the creation of a lamborghini
and failed
miserably man it was a crash and burn so
what i did was immediately
start watching tutorials on 3d modeling
and i learned so much
i know cinema 4d so in this video i'm
going to be breaking down my creative
process
for a fountain pen headphones a knife
and a water bottle so by the end of this
breakdown you guys can create photo reel
replicas of your favorite items
let's jump in extra is the sponsor of
today's video stick with me to the end
to figure out how you guys can get 20
off your extra wallet now the water
bottle was the easiest so this will be
level one for us
now for all these objects i decided to
use a subdivision modeling technique the
basic idea behind this modeling method
is to model a super low poly version of
your object
then throw it into a subdivision
modifier it's a standard technique
that's used across
all 3d programs blender gang i'm talking
to you guys
to keep our geometry as clean as
possible we want to keep things
in quads meaning all of our geometry
should just be four sided
triangles are evil and n-guns are
basically the devil
and my last note on subdivision modeling
is to use
edge loops to sharpen edges and corners
if you can model the low poly version of
your object
and use your edge loops to sharpen those
corners and edges then you guys
are set for success the last thing i
would wish
on my arch nemesis is for them to be
surprised by the sound
of a dropping hydro flask but that's how
you get these
dents on the water bottle right so all
i'm doing is pushing these points in
in polygon mode to get you that dented
look and texturing for all these objects
are actually pretty simple
i'm using a glossy material with surface
imperfections in the roughness channel
the gradient node is used to clamp the
black and white values to specific
shades of gray that give me
the right look and sometimes i'll throw
an imperfection in the specular channel
to say
black areas are reflective white areas
or not and i'll use that gradient note
again to work that look
for the bum channel i like to throw in a
bit of small scale noise to get a bit of
texture on the surface
the bump and normal channels are great
ways to get micro detail without relying
on your poly count
it makes things a little less computer
intensive i'm moving on
to the fountain pen
[Music]
so back in the early 2010s i used to
have a manager
he gifted me what has become one of my
favorite pens
it's a lamy fountain pen i've had many
since then but i think this is the
perfect thing to model and texture for
level two the only
reason i was able to model this stuff so
accurately is because i used
reference if you have the actual object
go ahead and get it because that's gonna
be the best way to go
the second best thing to do is go to
google and download some high-res
reference images and lay them out in a
program called pureref
this program changed it all for me i use
it to compile reference images and mood
boards
once you guys have your reference you
can start modeling the grip of this pen
as well as
the nib were the most difficult points
of this thing to model don't stop until
you guys get the likeness of the object
you're trying to model
keep going at it i promise you guys will
feel very fulfilled
as i did when i completed this model a
pro tip that helped me along the
creation process of
all of these objects was how to cut a
circle
out of a square so grab all your points
scale them
up and from here you can cut a hole or
extrude for the perfect circle don't
forget your edge loops though because
they're going to keep your geometry
sharp
i use this technique to get this oval
window to the inkwell
and be sure to adjust the scale of your
bump texture to match the distance in
which you're viewing your object
sometimes it's the best move to go for
what looks the nicest versus what is
actually accurate
and moving on to item number three bone
conduction headphones
these things are the best i've never had
a single item make such a difference
they work by vibrating the bones in your
skull modeling these headphones was a
big challenge for me it took
an entire four hour live stream to
complete these things which is why
they're landing in our level three
spot so like with all of these objects
they're getting more difficult at this
point but i really had to think about
how i modeled this
to me the earbud portion looked like
stretched cylinders and the bulky parts
look like cubes
so i start breaking this down into
primitives really focusing on the
spacing between
each object once i get the spacing right
between these two pieces i'll select
both
objects right click and select connect
objects plus delete
this combines these two pieces into one
so we can bridge the gap and then start
building out this neck piece
don't waste your time modeling stuff you
guys don't need the model
use symmetry modifiers when possible you
got symmetrical stuff
blender has this too you guys it doesn't
matter what program you're using these
are very basic things that most
3d programs have for textures again i'm
just using a surface imperfection in the
roughness channel and remember that the
gradient node controls the intensity of
your roughness so don't forget to use it
so you can match your reference as close
as possible
and finally we have the most difficult
of the four models for me
this pocket knife
combining everything we've learned so
far i am using reference
symmetry subdivision modeling and
surface imperfections controlled with
gradients to get my final object
my advice on something like this is to
start with a single polygon
and build out the shape of this flat
first
okay this way we can most efficiently
adjust the basic
shape of this thing before we start
building it out start with the simple
stuff
and then go from there one thing that
really helped me out with this model
right here was
saving iterations it's a way to save
past versions of your projects
i pulled from an early save file after i
screwed up one of the later iterations
now as far as textures go the only thing
that's new here is this type of metal
it's different from your standard chrome
material in the sense that it streaks
the reflections
you'll see this on cooking wear elevator
doors or fridges
it's called anisotropic metal and can
only be accessed in
octane if you change the brdf model to
something other than
octane crank the anisotropy up and give
it a bit of roughness if you still don't
see those streaks you can plug in a
skilled down octane noise into the bump
channel
now from this point it all comes down to
the lighting we can easily
just throw a random hdri and render our
scene
but why not use some strategically
placed lights
to really make these models shine and
look
their best now what i'm doing to get
this look is combining a number of soft
lights
with an hdri and remember generally the
bigger the light
the softer the shadows this aperture
light right here is
huge the reason you're getting these
nice soft shadows on here is because
we're looking at a giant
softbox this is really where we get to
have fun the modeling and stuff
all the hard work that's done now we get
to art direct it and
really let our object shine and finally
i'm using
depth of field to make my object seem a
bit more lifelike
i'm also combining that with a bit of
color correction and some bloom to make
things a little bit nicer
so if you guys have been following my
channel over the last year you guys know
that we do
weekly challenges so for this week i
challenge you guys to pick
one item and model that item all right
give it some texture
light it make it look really nice and on
next week's live stream i will critique
the five best renders and give them
my surface imperfection pack and all
four of these models that you just saw
to break down
and use for whatever you all want so all
you guys have to do is join the discord
the links in the description read the
weekly challenge and post under
submissions by saturday at 9 00 am
today's sponsor is extra the world's
largest smart
wallet brand they design innovative
solutions for the way you guys carry
your everyday items
just like this what makes these wallets
awesome is the solar powered tracking
card that you can ping with your phone
and vice versa if you ever lose your
phone so lucky for me i have one of
these in my extra wallet which is really
slick by the way it's much slimmer than
your traditional george wallet while
still offering a ton of space to work
with
the quick access feature is my favorite
it makes it feel like james bond when
you bust out your id
so click the link in the description to
get 20 off your extra
wallet and never lose the stuff that's
important to you
ever again
it's worth it pretty soon here i'm going
to announce a way that you guys can
download all my project
files and all of my assets and packs so
definitely subscribe for that i really
hope you guys learned something
i know i sure did so get out there and
start that weekly challenge
i hope to see your renders next week
peace guys
[Music]
so
you